there's been a discussion for a few
years now that Deep Space 9 copied
Babylon
5 but the most daming thing of
all I think I can live with
it but actually I think another show
might have been heavily inspired by it
as well welcome to srack your Sci-Fi TV
movie
[Music]
channel
the creator of Babylon 5 J Michael
shinski or JMS because it's easier to
say has actually had to comment on this
a few times because lots of fans have
talked about how they think starre Deep
Space 9 copied Babylon 5 now if we
ignore the fact that actually Deep Space
9 started before Babylon 5 because Deep
Space 9 started in 1993 and Babylon 5
started in 1994
prepare to engage the
[Music]
enemy so that sort of throws a spanner
in the works of that argument
immediately but actually a lot of the
argument is that it was the Dominion war
that started really in season three or
four um really got into the swing of
things in season three and four that was
actually what they copied and that would
have been a year after the third season
of Babylon 5 where they had the big
Shadow
conflict and the way Deep Space Nine
ended with all the fire gods and all
that stuff that did feel a bit Babylon
fan which isn't a word but we'll go with
it now I'm not saying that Deep Space 9
copy Babalon 5 I'm not saying that SGU
then copied battl Star Galactica but a
lot of these shows are inspired by each
other a Creator will see a new way of
doing things a new style of show and
they will you know be inspired by it
more importantly though Executives at
Studios will see a show being popular
and they will put pressure on creators
to do something similar I think that
happens quite a
lot so what is the show though I'm
talking about that I think was heavily
inspired by Babylon 5 that I've never
heard anybody talk about before and it
is Battlestar Galax IA that I think then
inspired Stargate
Universe why do I say that it's not
really the storyline obviously because
the storyline was replicating the
original series it's the style of the
show that I think Ronald D Moore was
very heavily inspired by Babylon
5 let them take the first
shot
all players Galactica threat
br350 carum 211 Raptors lean back as
missile pickets weapons free don't lose
me this time
Apollo oh not a chance now obviously
before Battle Star Galactica Ronald De
Moore did Star Trek he did Five Years on
deep space night he worked on Voyager as
well and he did a couple of years on
Star Trek the Next
Generation don't forget that if you're
enjoying the video and you want to help
support the channel we need your thumbs
up on the video and we need you to throw
a comment on it really helps with those
tricky little YouTube
algorithms he then went alone and
actually showrun battl Star Galactica
all
[Music]
right all forces engage any hostile
Target fire at will I repeat fire at
will take that you fren toaster Admiral
it's a silent trick
two an awful lot of critical Acclaim and
popularity it is still considered one of
the best sci-fi shows of the last couple
of decades and really stands out for its
individual style it's realistic Space
Battles the way the series was shot some
very unusual camera angles etc etc but
if you actually look at a lot of the
Space Battles Of Babylon 5 and then put
them alongside the Space Battles of
Battlestar Galactica they are very
similar if you think about it Babylon 5
again had very realistic Space Battles
they did the same thing as bsar
Galactica where they didn't use a lot of
sound during battles I think jmss
realized that space is a cold and Silent
place and he used silence very
effectively if you look at a lot of the
designs in Babylon 5 particularly say
the early Earth a rotating section so
they can create artificial gravity
because they hadn't actually developed
that technology like say the meari but
also look at the fighter design of the
star fury it's very realistic it really
is something that you could see that
would be very effective as a
fighter Battle Star Galactica had a very
similar idea it had designed SCI and
Technology aboard it that was very
realistic now obviously it was copying
the Original Series so it couldn't do
anything particularly original there but
still the technology was grounded just
like it was in Babylon 5 so for me no
Deep Space 9 it could have been inspired
by Babylon 5 because at the end of the
day Babylon 5 really does Stand Out
particularly back in the day as okay a
show that didn't have a great deal of
money spent on it but that every dollar
that was spent was on the screen it was
one of the first sci-fi shows to use
almost purely CGI Etc something that
Deep Space 9 didn't do in the first
couple of Seasons it really was out
there pushing the boundaries so of
course it's going to inspire other
creators but I think ronaldy Moore was
very heavily inspired by Babylon 5 and
he took that into Battlestar Galactica
now I don't know if he's conscious of
that or subconscious ious but really
when we look at a lot of the visuals
side by
side I can 100% see even though the
special effects on Battlestar Galactica
are obviously more advanced more
expensive and a little bit more refined
but I think the comparison is there for
all to see so yeah maybe Deep Space 9
was inspired by Babylon 5 but Battlestar
Galactica definitely was and it's not a
bad
thing but guys what do you think against
the comments was Babylon 5 really so far
ahead of its time it inspired TV shows
for decades following it I mean we talk
about Battle Star Galactica being a
genre defining series but really should
we be giving that mantle to babon 5 get
into the comments and tell me what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com citre
where most of our new videos premiere
and you get to see them without the
adverts for a small contribution each
month that supports the channel but you
get a free gift after three months also
go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on a lot of
our stories and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you you to digest go
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time